Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill Burns time for the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
November 5th,
2018 what's going on?
How are you?
Oh,
that's phenomenal.
Isn't that wonderful?
Hey everybody,
I don't know if you've heard,
I don't know if you've been on a TV or near a TV.
I don't know if few stream your thoughts at this point through some sort of
algorithm on a world wide network.
Um,
I don't know if you've heard this is for Americans only by the way,
people from the United States of America,
everybody else,
you know,
if you're in Australia,
just go stick a beat on something and fucking eat it during this time.
All right.
Cause this has nothing to do with you and that giant fucking
okay.
Can have a what?
Foster's lager,
whatever the fuck it is that in any you constrict down there,
that's why you stick it in a little fucking powder keg.
Like he just trying to get rid of it,
sending it our way.
Right.
Um,
that beer,
that's the Busch light of Australia anyways.
I've never had one.
I just judge it by the size of the can am like offsets that fucking good way.
You've given away by the bucketful anyways
for the people that this podcast truly represents.
And that would be the greatest people on this planet,
the people of the United States of America.
Um,
particularly the white people.
I'm fucking with you.
I'm going off Trump on here.
Sorry,
I'm reading a Trump speech.
Um,
it's a first draft of a Trump speech.
evidently tomorrow,
and I didn't know this,
I don't know if you're aware of this,
but I was not aware that tomorrow is evidently a very important day in politics,
quite Moslem way,
the most important
political day in history.
And you know something I had no idea,
but thank God all of these celebrities have taken time out of their day to let
me know how important it is.
You know what I mean?
Just when you think of celebrity cannot give more of themselves on screen after
they'd been driven over in a golf cart and add their fucking hair foof to buy
some fucking poor bastard in a trailer,
right.
Food to Poof,
whatever the fuck it is.
Thank God you know something.
And I've been so inspired by all of these celebrities letting me know what is
going on in my country.
You know what I mean?
Why would I listen to,
to,
to people who I don't know are in that business for a living.
Why would I listen to them when I can listen to somebody who's on a sitcom?
MMM.
And you know what?
I've been so inspired.
I actually think that going to,
uh,
I'm going to you.
Oh,
look who just calling in here.
Little facetime here.
My kiddo.
Hey Buddy.
Hi.
Hey Amy.
I'm doing the podcast.
I'm lily recording right now.
You guys are on the podcast.
Say Hi Dada.
Hi Sweetheart.
Hey.
Do you know tomorrow's a very important election day?
I did.
I'd be getting text messages round the clock about it.
I had no idea.
And then somebody,
uh,
well,
the third lead in a x man movie,
let me know that I need to get out there and vote.
I got an email from an actor as well.
Yeah.
I don't know why they're doing that.
I have a bad feeling that it's going to drive it the other way.
I was just in,
I was just in a a car service coming over from the airport and the guy goes,
I'm voting all red tomorrow.
All red.
All right.
I gotta get back to the podcast.
I'll see you guys later.
Bye Buddy.
Bye Sweetheart.
All right,
I'll see you in a minute.
Okay.
Um,
yeah.
Anyway,
so I think I'm going to do,
I am going to loan my podcast celebrity to try and inspire some of you to get
out there tomorrow.
Get out there and vote.
And when I say vote,
I don't mean go out and decide who you think is the right candidate.
I want you to go out there and vote.
Who for who?
I want you to vote for.
Okay.
I'm loaning my podcast celebrity and I feel like more so than that,
I'm actually going to be honest with you
as a person in your public ears rather than just being like trying to be like
non,
you know,
committal here and just say get out there and vote.
I want you to vote.
Who,
who I want you to vote for.
Okay?
I don't know who to vote for him.
Maybe.
Maybe somebody that hosted game show could tell me.
I watch CNN and Fox News all the time.
I'm informed.
I read the Sunday New York Times.
Shut up.
Jesus.
Do these fucking people understand that there's,
there's engineers and doctors,
you know I'm too stupid to name another smart job.
Veterinarian.
The guy who knows how to hook up your fucking cable.
I mean,
these are smart people.
They know it's an important fucking election.
They know who they're voting for.
All right?
I got a bad feeling that they're going to get this wrong.
The same way they got the election wrong.
You know,
I actually think that have celebrities wanted this blue wave.
They should shut up
because do you know people who are on the red side are also watching this shit?
It's like you're broadcasting to the Japanese during World War Two when you're
going to attack,
why would you do that?
You gotta get on your own frequency,
right?
Oh,
who should I vote for?
Maybe two near row could tell me,
hey,
I like that guy's movies.
Maybe I like his political choices.
MMM.
Do you remember back in the day when you just,
you know,
you didn't bring up politics and you didn't bring up religion and you sat there
and you hate your fucking cheese sandwich,
you know,
and you just said that was it.
Every fucking,
you know,
you got to get out there and vote.
And by vote,
I mean vote who I'm going to vote for.
Oh my God,
what is wrong with this country?
How come everybody doesn't see it the way I see it?
Anyways,
having said that,
I usually vote,
but I'm going to be here in New York and I didn't file for the absentee thing,
you know?
So whoever's not liking this should be happy that I just cancelled out my vote,
you know,
and one of the most important elections of all time.
And you know why it's important because the same five corporations that have the
money on all the horses in the race this time decided to just put it on one side
of the ball evidently.
So we will move towards a more prosperous future for the middle class
because someone's finally going to have to regulate the banks again.
Is that what we're voting for?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
Hey,
you know what,
I'm going to loan,
I'm going to loan my podcast celebrity right now and I'm going to solve the
problems of the Middle East right now.
First thing I would do,
I would go over there.
I would tell everybody to grow up.
Okay.
As far as I can tell you all worship the same thing.
Um,
no,
this is what I would do.
I would,
uh,
I would break up with Iraq as the first thing I would do.
I would just sit down and just say,
listen,
I wreck,
I'm not happy.
This isn't working out.
I know,
I know.
I came in like gang busters.
I moved in within a week with this just whole relationship,
just moved way too quickly.
All right.
And I just,
you know,
it's not the I,
I love you,
but I don't love you in a way that makes me want to stay.
And I would just get the fuck out.
We can keep this Starbucks and all these fucking things,
right?
All right,
switch over to solar power.
I would do all of this on the same day.
By the way,
in my world,
you can actually do this.
Switch over to solar power.
Take that lunatic over a Tesla.
You know
d,
uh,
he looks like the guy,
Ian Mcshane,
if he had a nervous breakdown or so,
I don't know what the fuck that fucking guy,
right?
I would just all electric all the fucking time,
I'd have a big campaign where I bring back the electric slide and everybody
fucking enough mouth breathers would do it and they would get behind it and then
we're not no more money to the Middle East.
All right,
for oil.
Then they'd all go bankrupt and the second we leave,
they go back to kicking the shit out of each other.
You know what I mean?
The same way,
when Russia left Eastern Europe,
everybody was happy for about three days and they all started killing each other
again.
They were like,
oh yeah,
where,
where are we?
That's right.
God said we're better.
Right.
And they just went right back to that shit.
So you leave.
Yeah,
you got to look fucking solar power and all that fucking shit going on.
I don't know if he knows about the Middle East.
Middle East always reminded me of,
there was used to be this store in the South Shore Plaza that I used to go to
before they did the remodel.
You know when it was all brown and seventies looking,
I swear to God,
I think the floor was made out of vinyl.
It was some sort of rubber.
Anyway,
they used to have these little kiosks in the middle of all these big stores,
almost like a like little moons to these giant fucking planets of stores.
And one of them was called Wickson sticks and all they sold was candles.
And even as a little kid I was like,
how are they stay in
open?
Like that's all they sell.
You know,
if people ever stopped fucking or raw doing Voodoo,
like these people are going to be in trouble.
So I look at like the Middle East,
like they're like a giant Wickson and sticks like where at Wix is sticks just,
just sold candles.
They're just sell an oil.
That's their main thing.
If you stop buying their oil,
they don't have any money.
They don't have any money.
They can't,
can't finance a fucking military.
Right.
Meanwhile they can't have endangered species as pets.
So that's a two for right there.
They slowly go out of fucking business.
We're over here with their fucking a,
I dunno,
fucking electric cars and shit.
Not saying it's cleaner for the environment,
but it gets you out of that shit.
If elected tomorrow ladies and gentlemen,
I will,
I will present a three day plan to get us out of the Middle East and off of oil.
That would be implemented immediately.
Okay.
Despite the crushing effects on the economy.
I'm sorry.
And I'm just,
I've just,
I don't need somebody who is in fucking third rock from the sun.
Okay.
You know,
talking to me about this,
but you know,
at the end of the day,
I am not voting.
I would have voted,
but I'm just on the road.
So what,
what am I supposed to do?
Well,
Bill,
you could apply for an absentee ballot.
Um,
well I would,
but the people that I vote for never win
cause they hate the Democrats.
They,
the Republican Party.
I vote for those lunatics.
There's people that are like,
I don't know man.
If we voted for this guy and he got in,
I don't know,
either things would get better or everything would be on fire.
Like those are the people that I vote for.
So maybe I shouldn't vote.
Maybe I'm one of those people.
Yeah.
We'll be right back with podcasts.
Celebrities who don't vote.
MMM.
As a podcast celebrity.
I just like saying that,
that makes me feel important.
Um,
speaking of important,
I have a couple of important announcements to make.
Um,
okay.
I'm going to be at Madison Square Garden on Wednesday,
the day after the election.
I think I'm still going to be like telling people what they should vote for.
That's how full of myself I am.
The day after the election,
you know what you should've done.
You know,
like somebody calls up a sport shelf the day after the team fucking losers.
Um,
all right.
important announcement.
My patrion page,
www.patrion.com/birth five bucks a month.
Every month you get two episodes of uninformed but me and old Joey roses.
Um,
I got a,
uh,
let's see,
live from the live Monday morning podcast that I filmed,
I did in front of a live studio on it.
Fuck it.
We'll do it live in Phoenix or you can download that from the pastry on app to
stream,
um,
that in new uninformed episodes or download directly to your phone.
I have behind the scenes and a,
the forum behind the scenes backstage I should say.
And uh,
you have some helicopter video and I'm just going to keep adding to that every
month.
It's at www.patrion.com/bar.
Uh,
that's it.
What else do I have?
I think that was it.
Um,
other than that,
I went up and
I visited my family back east and I went to the Patriots Green Bay packers game,
obviously was very excited.
What the outcome of that game.
I was,
because Aaron Rodgers is such a fucking beast.
And uh,
yeah,
I was nervous about our defense against them and uh,
you know,
played a little Ben don't break in the red zone.
Uh,
he kind of had all day to pass for most of the game,
but when it counted,
we got in his fucking grill and made it happen.
Um,
and I had great seats,
you know,
I have to tell Jimmy Kimmel that I sit up,
up top with the fucking real people actually got into one of those boxes.
No sitting right in the front fucking row.
MMM.
They had the window open and shit.
It was great.
So I was like cold.
But then when I walked into the back near the food,
I was all warm.
Like it was in somebody's living room.
I got treated like an absolute king.
So I want to thank the Patriots.
Um,
when we got the whole trip,
I got to see the,
uh,
the trophies.
I got to talk to Andre Tippett.
I mean,
it was,
it was incredible.
It was fucking incredible.
And then I watched arguably two of the greatest quarterbacks of all time.
One of them is the greatest quarterback of all time.
And then the other one,
I don't know,
you know,
what are we going to put him?
But he's the only halfway done,
you know,
he's just fucking kicking the shit out of everybody.
He's on track.
Right.
He's on track to be what top five every has got to be.
You know,
I bet if he,
if he wasn't doing what he was doing and Green Bay,
you know,
if he was doing it in a different city like New York,
he probably already be there.
You gotta to work twice as hard,
twice as hard and green bay.
I feel like,
like can you imagine me in the greatest quarterback of all time?
And you're in Buffalo,
New York.
Yeah.
Green Bay,
Wisconsin.
Like how long would it take people to notice?
Um,
we're taking collars?
No,
it was an amazing game.
And um,
set.
That's maybe the third time I've seen Aaron Rodgers play live.
He just always leaves one of those guys where he starts to run and then he could
throw the fucking ball.
You Think,
oh,
he's going to run for like eight Yah we did.
He just got 30 yards.
Like how good he is at that is,
it's like drives you up the fucking wall when you're watching your team cause
you like tag them.
Okay.
They got him getting at how he slipped away.
Now Dick Chap called before he gets it,
throws it down the goddamn field.
Yeah,
I bet people were like,
well bitch,
and it's some of our quarterbacks,
it's like,
dude,
dead a damn.
They'd been running around back there for like six seconds.
Like something should have happened by now.
They shouldn't still have to be covering a receiver.
MMM.
But anyways,
uh,
I kind of called it before the game,
I kind of feel,
and Josh Gordon was going to have a breakout game,
which I feel like he did.
I couldn't tell and I wasn't watching any sort of broadcast.
So let's say you've jammed his fingers or something on two plays in a row.
He was looking at his hands.
I hope he's all right.
And then that Patterson dude just took over before the half.
Yeah,
just unstoppable.
Just handing the ball off to this hybrid running back wide receiver.
I mean,
how perfect is that for Bella checks on offense.
Um,
so here we go.
We're six and two,
but fucking Kansas City one again.
So there,
what this seven and one,
I don't fucking know.
I got a kid now.
I have no idea.
So as a right now we would play.
Okay.
Kansas City at home provided we got to the AFC championship game and uh,
I tell you that would be,
that'd be a tall order trying to beat those guys.
Two tabs one year.
Um,
once again,
people freaking out about,
uh,
my homes.
He threw a ball like 90 yards.
Oh,
you mean like Doug Williams did 30 years ago?
Sorry.
Um,
I've never seen anything like this.
Alright.
Lsu versus Alabama.
Oh,
Jesus.
that one hurt.
Oh,
did that one hurt?
I was like,
Alabama hasn't fucking played anybody.
Let's look at their fucking schedule.
Right.
Cause this is what I was doing.
I was like,
you know something.
Even though our fucking best defensive players going to be on the bench for the
first fucking half,
I feel like we're going to hang with them.
Then the other kid comes in.
Maybe he can,
uh,
you know.
Okay.
Tip the scale and Ellis shoes.
Favor.
That did not happen.
Can I spell Alabama,
Alabama football schedule 2018 let's listen to these powerhouses that Alabama
has played a Mississippi state.
That's not bad.
Auburn.
Oh,
this is what they have left.
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
Hang on a sec.
Hang on a second.
Auburn.
They play harbor and everyday of every fucking Thanksgiving bill.
All right.
They played Louisville.
Okay.
One 51 to 14.
Then they played Mississippi.
Okay.
Then they played Louisiana Lafayette.
Then they played Missouri or whatever.
I think I'm fucking up these.
None of these teams are ranked.
They played Arkansas state.
They played Texas a and m not Alabama's fault.
The Texas a and M is not good right now.
Then they played Arkansas,
not their fault.
They played Tennessee.
They played Missouri.
This is Lsu is the first fucking ranked team they played all year.
So I'm thinking like,
well they're finally fucking playing somebody.
Let's see what happens.
And they went in there and they just fucking kicked him right in the Dick.
I mean it just,
it offense couldn't do shit.
Okay.
The defense just dominated him.
It's,
it's like they just stuck a rag in their mouth and fucking wrap some duct tape
right around them.
I always fit and just repeatedly kicked him in the nuts slowly for four straight
quarters,
uh,
29 to nothing.
So all those haters out there,
you know.
Yeah,
they don't play shit,
but it's not their fault.
It's not their fault that everybody kind of sucks at their plan.
But then when they do play a number three team,
they fucking destroyed them.
So,
uh,
they got Mississippi state and then the biggest challenge of the year,
they play sit at all
and then they got a Auburn.
And then for some reason there's a game on the 1st of December.
I would've thought that that was the last one.
They're playing Georgia.
So they,
they got some teams coming up,
not really.
Um,
but does just say there'll be nice and rested for when they played for yet
another championship,
but you know,
something as much as people bitch about that,
you know,
they're easy scheduled,
then they get into the championship game and more times than not,
they win,
you know,
as opposed to Ohio state.
I remember a few years ago,
they fucking,
they Penn state beat them straight up and then also won the big 10
championships.
And for some reason Penn state didn't get in,
but Ohio state did.
And then I'll state went down there.
I got that fucking shorts.
She yanked down.
Um,
I'm in way over my head right now.
I don't even know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Um,
but I could just tell you as a podcast celebrity,
your vote on who should be,
who should make the Ncaa College football playoff is extremely important.
It's extremely important that this Saturday coming up is one of the most
important Saturdays in college football history.
And who would know better than his celebrity podcast?
Oh,
that sounds better,
doesn't it?
I'm gonna have to put that on my fucking,
mmm.
I guess say put it on my Wikipedia page,
comedian,
actor,
celebrity,
podcaster.
Uh,
please don't put that on there.
Well,
I've already said to do it.
So now it's,
and that was done.
Um,
anyways,
um,
so I'm hanging here in New York,
going to do my little tuneup show tonight,
bounce around some clubs here in New York.
Uh,
looking forward to that.
And then,
uh,
I got my big shoe on,
um,
on Wednesday,
so I'm just sitting here and then I got,
I got three shows in Chicago,
um,
at the Chicago theater on Thursday,
Friday and Saturday.
And then all freckles is fucking done for the year I've done for the year.
So I mean,
uh,
not,
I mean I got some local shows that I'm doing,
but um,
and I will not be doing shit again until I go out to eastern Europe,
which I already made fun of on this podcast.
When are we announcing those dates?
I don't know.
I think I just pictured the hedge.
I just picked the headshot they were going to use or something to that nature.
So any day now.
And um,
oh,
you know what?
Fuck this.
I'm just going to tell you this.
I want to tell you the fucking cities.
I'm going to be it,
but I'm not going to tell you the dates.
All I'm going to do is tell you that it fucking,
it.
It starts on,
um,
what is it?
January 2nd.
All right,
here we go.
Let's see if I can find it here.
Oh,
Ho Ho Bailey.
When a year ago in
so fucking eastern Europe.
Well,
where the fuck are they?
that's not it.
Oh,
why is it fucking motherfucker?
What?
Why aren't you showing me?
What the Fuck I want?
All right.
You know what I'm just gonna put in Eastern Europe.
How about TJ's Europe?
Eastern Europe.
Okay.
Ah,
right.
Okay.
All right.
I'm just going to,
I'm going to be in Prague,
Vienna,
Berlin,
Warsaw,
Latvia.
I didn't know whether it is Lithuania,
Estonia,
Bulgaria.
Yeah.
Cologne.
Munich,
often back.
Germany,
Budapest,
Hungary.
I might've read those kind of backwards.
Um,
that's going to be from January 3rd until a Sunday.
January 13th,
10 days.
And I'm bringing Paul Versey with me.
And he's going to go over there with his fucking blue Yankee hat and his fucking
joy dude,
eastern Europe,
Jordan's sexes
over over.
We uh,
I'm actually,
it came in town early cause we had a surprise birthday party for Paul.
And um,
when I tell you like,
you know,
when you go to those things and like the person's kind of figured it out and
then he tried to act like the surprise and you know that the not like Versie
legit had no fucking clue.
He was coming down the stairs and I could tell the way he was talking,
it was at this restaurant,
the way he was talking to this guy,
I was like,
oh my God,
this guy has like no clue.
And then I got like nervous for a second.
Like is he going to have like a fucking heart attack?
What if he just breaks down and starts crying?
Like I always there,
you guys,
you know,
just gets really fucking awkward.
I got,
I got like,
really,
I don't like doing that to people.
You know what I mean?
You know,
let them know what's going on.
Okay.
He just came,
walked around the corner,
we all just go surprise.
And he did like a fucking double take,
put his hand up to his face and then just walked out of the room for a second.
But it was funny.
Everybody laughed and then he came back
and uh,
oh my God,
we had a great time.
Okay.
It's like this whiskey tasting thing.
It was just amazing.
It was fucking amazing.
This guy was given us all this whole fucking history lesson on whiskey to a
bunch of comedians.
So it's like we're in class with this subject we always wanted to take,
but at the end of the day,
we're all class clowns,
so everybody's trying to outdo each other.
And this Guy Ethan,
who did the tour just handled it like a champ.
You know,
we gave him shit a little bit.
He gave a shit back.
Um,
it was,
uh,
it was just such a fucking great time.
Then he had,
if somebody,
they can roll in cigars.
It was really a,
it was amazing.
And then I went up to the Patriots game.
Yeah,
you know this,
this is what it's like people to be a celebrity pie rms stuff with that joke.
All right.
Anyways,
so I'm back here in New York and uh,
I was watching today on ESPN.
Um,
they said the Lakers hit a new low and the Lebron era,
it's like the just fucking started.
It's like a month into it.
Magic Johnson said that are on a two year plan.
The first year is going to be rough and then they're going to clear all this cap
space and they're going to buy a bunch of people and make a run at fucking a,
yeah.
Oh,
the golden state.
I mean,
the guy said that you said,
that's what I'm going to do.
I don't understand.
Okay.
Why Espn is trying to make me act like this is like this big failure and Luke
Walton needs to be fired.
They said it's a two year plan.
We're barely fucking,
not even two months into this.
Jesus Christ,
he fucking ESPN.
I swear to God,
they're worst than CNN and Fox.
So I don't watch any of those channels.
I just said,
just tell,
tell me who won the game.
Yeah,
get me all fucking anxious.
Um,
we had a meeting with Luke Walton and they said it wasn't,
you know,
it didn't concern his job,
but could it Ben,
his kidneys,
sorry.
Anyways,
um,
I actually have been going to the gym out here in New York and,
uh,
you know,
I had a little bit of set,
a little bit of a setback with my shoulder.
Now back.
Um,
the person I was working with was telling me what I could do,
like 120 pounds,
like 10 times on the lat pull down with the weight that I'm at.
I could attempt to do a pull up.
My shoulder would be,
but you know,
one to three,
which means I would just do one.
And uh,
you know,
I took a few days off.
I tried to come back where I left off.
I was up to 110 pounds and I felt a little tweak.
I fucking stopped immediately shut the whole thing down.
Ice My shoulder and I was fine,
but I had to go back down to about 75 pounds.
Just these fucking rotator cuffs to such,
they're so delicate.
You know what I mean?
It's like a,
you don't like,
uh,
what?
Like someone who's just a needy self centered asshole,
like their group of friends.
Yeah.
It's just like a,
I don't what their deal is.
They're like a,
it's like this entourage of people.
Like that's Kinda like what,
uh,
you rotator cuff is like that person,
you know,
if your shoulder muscles were a bunch of different people built,
what are you talking about?
I don't know.
I'm just trying to fill fucking time.
Let me read some advertising here.
How about that?
Huh?
Did I,
did I copy and paste the advertising?
I don't think I did.
Here we go.
My age is probably going to give me shit for reading those fucking names of
those cities.
I mean,
what am I supposed to do?
I've been,
I've been pre hyping it for awhile
by the way,
that my eastern European tour is going to be one of the most important standup
tours
in the history of eastern European standup tourists by bald,
redheaded males who grew up in Massachusetts,
south of Boston.
All right.
Oh my bookie.
Everybody a show watch footballs far more.
Would you like to have a little bit of [inaudible] she audit,
but it's more entertaining when you have some action on the games.
Guys,
you've heard me talk about this for weeks and some of you are still on the
sideline like a bunch of Mary's.
Uh,
whether you're an expert or a rookie,
you should be betting my bookie that my bookie,
if you're the kind of guy that likes to bet a little and when a lot like playing
the numbers on roulette,
you can create a big parlay,
pick three teams to win and it'd be hit all three.
You could turn $100 into 600 bucks.
I never do the parlays.
That's like fucking doing a murder with somebody else.
You know,
somebody is going gonna rat somebody up.
You know what I mean?
I do individual bets.
Um,
anyways,
there's just so much to bet on.
Playoff baseball,
basketball,
hockey,
primetime fights,
and more.
Also make sure to follow bet at,
oh,
sorry.
At bet my bookie on Twitter or Instagram,
they personally respond to every mentioned in DM.
Not to mention they've given away nearly $10,000 in free money to their fellow,
to their followers this football season.
You'll be the first to know as soon as the odds and PR on props are posted.
A log onto my bookie right now.
Don't miss out on your last opportunity to collect the industry's biggest bonus.
Use Promo Code Burr and you'll get your first deposit matched 100%.
That's Promo Code burb you are,
are you play,
you win,
you get paid or you lose,
you pay.
And maybe your girlfriend breaks up with you.
Just giving you all the possibilities here.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
I don't read all his shit.
Frame Bridge.
Okay.
Um,
if you've been listening to this show,
you've heard me talk about frame bridge,
the most important framed bridges.
Yeah.
Okay.
Tomorrow on Tuesday.
Uh,
they make it super easy and affordable to frame your favorite things from our,
I just immediately pictured so many framing their dick for some reason from art
prints and posters to the travel sitting on your phone.
Here's how it worked.
Just go to [inaudible] Dot Com and upload your photo.
Or they'll send you packaging to safely male in your
male and your physical pieces.
Yeah,
and we're back to Dick's again.
Yeah.
Um,
preview your item online in any frame style.
Choose your favorite or get free recommendations from their talented designers,
the expert team at Cambridge.
What custom frame your item and deliver your finished piece directly to your
door.
Ready to hang instead of the hundred you'd pay it a framing store.
Their prices start at just $39 and all the shipping is free.
Plus my listeners will get 15% off their first order at [inaudible] dot com when
they used my code Burr,
get started today.
Frame your photo or send the perfect gift for weddings,
birthdays,
and special events.
Go to frame bridge.com and use Promo code bar.
You'll save an additional 15% off your first order.
Just go to frame,
bridge.com Promo Code Bar.
Hey.
Okay.
Frame which.com Promo Code Barb.
All right.
There's three left.
Let's take a break here.
Shall We?
From reading?
We fucking eyes hurt.
Yeah.
MMM.
Okay.
Let me see.
Feminist cheerleaders.
Somebody was saying that they have a problem with the cheerleaders.
Should we let our girls be cheerleaders?
Is it time to rethink the rules for NFL cheerleaders?
Um,
okay.
Let's see what day,
what it was.
See what the fucking problem is.
What is the problem now?
Okay.
40 years ago,
this month,
a visitor at the Dallas cowboys cheerleading tryouts described a scene that was
quote as tense as an open casting call for a Broadway production with 150 woman,
the most envied,
celebrated,
and sought after in the country.
Shivering in an overly air conditioned room.
Aw.
That's like being backstage at Letterman.
It was fucking freezing.
Uh,
the women's spoke of starvation diets that had lasted for weeks.
This sounds like when you've got a movie career from here coming up.
Uh,
the visitor,
a New York Times reporter noted that the cheerleaders were paid next to nothing,
$15 a game.
They had stringent practice schedules as much as five hours a night,
five nights a week.
The only thing I agree with is how little they pay.
They should pay more and they could not appear where alcohol was served at 10
parties of any sword or wear jewelry with the uniforms.
A cowboy cheerleader above all else is beautiful.
The article said at a time when the squad was perhaps the most iconic such case,
so what is the fucking problem?
For decades later,
the world may have changed,
but the rules of professional cheerleading appear to be essentially the no.
Okay.
These people,
they don't even know what the fuck they're talking about.
First of all,
cheerleaders,
they used to lead cheers before there was diamond v.
Dot.
The big fucking whatever you call them,
the big fucking flat screens and all the music go,
go short it and all that shit.
You know,
everybody clap your hands before all of that shit.
They would lead people in chairs,
but then when it became obsolete,
so now what they really are,
is it just sort of dance teams and then when there's a stoppage of play,
they come out,
oh,
Bobo Bobo.
Break it down right there.
You just do something.
I just do some shit.
And this is just,
once again,
I swear to God,
this is just,
this is just fucking,
I'm telling you,
like the women who are going to complain about this,
no one's going to ask you to be a cheerleader.
This is like me being concerned with the models at copper tone being like,
are they being,
you know,
tanning is not the most healthiest thing.
And in the end it's really,
I'm just jealous because I don't have any pigment and look according to the
Internet,
like a mongoloid.
MMM.
Is it time to rethink those?
I don't think I've ever seen with all of the true,
huge fucking gigantic
fucking problems out there.
I don't think I've ever seen a time where just like the most frivolous shit
gets,
gets bumped all the way up to the top.
It's like all those fucking assholes that somehow board the plane before group
one.
Will you just look at how the fuck did that person get on to people today got
on,
not veterans.
No kids not limping.
Somehow got on before.
Everybody else is just like,
what the fuck did they do?
And my buddy just sent me something.
This is going to be the new scam in aviation.
Is everybody just paying money and extra shit just to be able to get on that
fucking point.
First,
my buddies,
uh,
Dean del Ray sent me this thing.
It's like five grand a year.
Okay.
Five fucking grand a year.
You go to the,
you go to your own private terminal at lax and then,
then they take you right to the plane and you get on first.
So you know what?
I decided,
I was like,
you know what?
I'm just going to pack less.
Okay,
well I'm going to be old Billy backpack and my backpack will fit right
underneath my fucking chair.
And then you guys in.
Anybody else wants to fucking,
yeah.
You know,
sit there like,
like a,
like a bunch of fucking hyenas.
Okay.
Trying to get the spoils of a lions kill.
I am.
I'm not fucking doing it.
All right.
I'm going to fucking hang back.
Yeah.
And be like,
all right,
all you fucking,
I,
I quit.
Okay.
I did it the right way.
I started in the back of the,
I worked my way up.
I was promised a gold watch and the gold watch was that I was going to get on
first.
It just doesn't fucking exist anymore.
MMM.
Anyways,
what is a,
what the fuck was I talking about?
Yeah.
Oh yes.
So there's all these lashelle like,
so,
you know,
it's funny,
I just,
I just did what these feminists to doing,
right.
Rather than dealing with overpopulation,
climate change,
fucking uh,
uh,
deregulated banks.
We're going to tackle cheerleading.
Why?
Because it affects me then.
I love that.
I went on that fucking rant about people getting on the plane first.
Cause I just showed him just this fucking bad to say are,
you know,
so God bless them.
Let them bitch above a fucking job.
They're never going to be offered.
Yeah.
How fucking full of yourself are you.
Should I let my daughter cheerlead what she good.
Looking enough.
Should I let my son be the head of,
of the math team?
Well,
did your son get your fucking,
I'm actually making fun of myself here.
You're,
you're fucking it up.
Should I let my kid read out loud on the radio?
A No bill for the love of God know.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
policy genius.
Everybody.
That was just a little break.
Yeah.
That's what feminists are concerned about.
Now.
Cheerleading.
Hmm.
Hey,
there's a swirl.
A trash two times the size of Texas to biles deep out in the Pacific Ocean.
I don't give a fuck.
Pull a pom poms.
Okay.
Um,
I don't give a shit.
Let's talk about cheerleading.
All right.
Policy genius.
Life Insurance isn't the most enjoyable thing to think about.
Most people don't like thinking about dying.
I can tell you right now,
I've got a life insurance policy and now all of a sudden I,
I,
you know,
I know it's like a weight off my chest.
It's like I can fucking leave now.
And,
and nobody's going to have a problem.
And I'm not talking about dying,
I'm talking about going out,
getting a pack of smokes and never coming back.
Uh,
but actually having life insurance is a really good feeling.
As I just said,
I literally feel like I could abandoned my family.
Like that's how relieved I am that I have life insurance.
It's nice to know that if anything were to happen to you,
I immediately pictured a piano.
Did anybody ever bring a piano up with a fucking rope?
Did that really happen?
And why would somebody walk underneath?
Um,
anything can happen to you.
Your family won't have to start a go fund me to stay afloat.
Well,
here's my question.
What happens if something happens to my family?
What about the guy here?
Huh?
When do I get to fucking put my feet up?
Okay.
Uh,
motivate your audience.
Talk about your experience with the product slash service.
Choose one to two copy points to rotate into your,
okay.
Um,
well,
I already told you how much I like life insurance.
I just did it before you guys advertised here.
So I didn't use policy genius,
but you know,
had there,
had I known that there was a policy genius out there,
I would have used it and what it saved myself a fucking small fortune.
Right?
My loved ones would be in Kavia rather than tuna fish.
Okay.
Policy is the easiest way to get life insurance online and just two minutes.
You can compare quotes from the top insurers to find the best policy for you.
And when you compare quotes,
you save money.
It's that simple.
Policy Genius has helped over 4 million people shop for insurance and placed
over $20 billion in coverage and they don't just make life insurance easy.
They also compare disability insurance,
auto insurance,
and home insurance.
If you care about it,
they cover it.
Call to action.
So if you've been avoiding getting life insurance because it's difficult to
confusing,
I don't get it mayor,
give policy genius to try.
Just go to policy genius.com fro you dummies out there.
That's Pol.
I see why g and ius genius is such a hard word to spell,
isn't it?
Get Your quotes and apply in minutes.
You can do the whole thing on your phone right now.
Policy Genius be easy way to compare.
I mean by Lavan Jerry's that whole time I was just thinking about those,
the fucking cheerleader thing,
you know,
I had to starve myself and everything.
Hey,
you mean make sacrifices?
Well,
get a fucking nutritionist.
You don't have to starve.
You just have to eat foods that fuel your body.
Yeah.
If you could sit a star.
I like how like you know,
Oh,
have you ever seen real starving people?
What?
The distended bellies and you can count their fucking rib cage.
Lionel Hampton could come over and play a fucking song on that goddamn torso,
that starving.
All right.
These poor women starved themselves.
The air conditioning is turned on too low.
Just imagine
living in some fucking war torn country and listening to that fucking argument.
I think one of the biggest problems facing women today is the question of
cheerleading.
All right.
He likes everybody Hallux.
You ever wake up in the morning?
We'll do.
Yeah.
With regrets of what you've done.
Jesus Christ.
Telltale heart is your roommate buried underneath your floorboards and your best
friend,
dad.
The cop is coming over a reef laying the terrible decisions you've made the
previous night over and over and over.
Jesus Christ.
Yes.
The kicking,
sweating,
yelling or whatever she did to piss off everyone in the bedroom.
Well,
guess what,
Bud?
Deciding to sleep on a shitty mattress is your choice.
MMM.
Wait a second.
You telling me if I have a nice mattress,
I won't regret decisions I made as a younger man.
This might be the greatest sales pitch I've ever heard in my life.
What else can it do?
Are you sick of your dick staring down at your ball bag when you wake up in the
morning?
Wouldn't it be great if it was fucking pointing at the ceiling?
Is it to say there's a fucking raccoon up there?
Be careful.
Um,
anyways,
what the hell am I here?
Sang to sleep on a shitty mattress is your choice.
But bill,
buying a mattress is so hard.
Where would I ever begin?
Well,
you're in luck buddy,
because he likes sleep.
The Mat,
the mattress.
I've been yelling at you to buy for almost two years will change your life.
Go to helix,
sleep.com/bird.
Take their two minutes sleep quiz and the match you to the perfect mattress.
What kind of a creep reads other people's sleep quiz and you're naked when you
sleep.
Oh yeah.
Teachers were the talks in the bottoms.
Um,
it's like Tinder for them for finding a mattress.
All the fun with none of the next morning regrets and misery.
And right now you can get up to a dollar 25 off your mattress order at helix,
sleep.com/bar they have $100 a hundred night trial.
Free shipping at won't send you creepy next day.
Texts.
That's helix sleep.com/burr for up to $125 off your mattress order.
Oh lastly,
but certainly not leastly,
certainly not leastly stamps.com stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters or packages at your convenience.
24,
seven print postage for any male class right from your own computer.
The exact amount of postage every time.
Never underpay or overpay.
You did.
I would tell you guys,
I majored in communications.
Let me try my,
my broadcasting voice.
I don't you,
I don't know.
You're here we go stamps.
So I carbs saves you time and money which you can use to grow your business.
stamps.com brings all the amazing services of the US post office right to your
fender.
Fingertips buy and print official US postage for any letter,
any package,
any class of mail using your own computer or printer stamps.com makes it so
easy.
Even your stupid kid can do it.
They'll send you a digital scale,
automatically calculates exact postage stamps.com we'll even help you decide the
best class of mail based on your needs.
You can even take your daughter and put her on the scale and way or just to see
if she's light enough to be a cheerleader.
Um,
no need to lease an expensive postage meter and there are no long term
commitments and right now you too can enjoy the stamps.com service with a
special offer that includes a four week trial plus postage and a digital scale
scale.
Sorry,
go to stamps.com.
Click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbarthatstamps.com enter
[inaudible] there.
Go.
Now let's get onto the questions for this week.
Question Number One,
am I too fat to be a cheerleader?
MMM.
If I continue to take it in the face,
well that extra protein make me beautiful enough.
These are the hard hitting questions in cheerleading.
All right,
Paul Versey special.
Hey Bill,
I just watched the Paul bursaries forsee special and just wanted to thank you
for promoting it.
Look at that.
It was hilarious and I can't wait for the next all things comedy special on
comedy central.
Keep up the great podcast.
You Maniac.
Oh yeah.
Paul Versey special did very,
very,
very well.
So I want to thank everybody for watching that.
Um,
[inaudible] I'm sure they got it streaming on their website.
You know how those guys are.
Everybody knows what they're doing over comedy central.
And,
um,
Paul's just the first week we're going to,
we've got three more specialists come in and we're picking all comics that other
comics like.
And,
um,
I'm very proud of the group that we have common.
I'm not allowed to say who they are when I can.
I will.
All right.
That's it.
Advice for olive oil,
olive oil,
uh,
number one.
Uh,
okay.
Benito.
Billy.
I'm another 22 year old lady
and longterm lover of the podcast and truly all of your work to be honest,
as an Amazonian myself,
just shy of six feet.
All this is for that woman who wrote in olive oil.
Um,
I wanted to reach out and offer some advice to my girl olive oil from last week.
I co sign everything you said about loving yourself and some guy will love you
just the way you are.
But I just wanted to put my 2 cents of advice in as well.
Joe Jesus,
get on with it there which is lift some weights.
Girl.
Thankfully my prayers were answered around the time I reached adulthood and the
form of a nice little waist to hip ratio and suggests praise God.
But I was never satisfied with my rear end and tell it.
I met my husband who is jacked and he introduced me to pumping iron and iron and
Schwartzenegger blesses hard,
taught me how to sculpt an ass out of muscle.
I suggest she watches that movie,
starts with the basic no supplements except create team weight gainer and
coffee.
Don't waste money on any of the bullshit GNC concoctions and find some heavy
stuff to lift in the following ways.
Squad bench deadlift.
Uh,
now she will get so much self confidence out of becoming stronger than she has
ever been.
You know,
I would just say get a personal trainer too.
So you doing all of this right?
You don't fuck up your back.
Um,
and with the endorphins from exercise plus the changes in her body adding mass,
I really think she will love it.
Number two,
the tall skinny girl.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
What the fuck is this doing here?
I don't want to update now it's looking.
No,
sorry.
Number two,
the tall skinny girl who wrote in a should move to New York and be worshipped.
I feel for her though,
because people used to tell me stuff like that to my face all the time.
They would just tell him he a call your stretch,
you know?
Well,
and then let's type the type of shit,
you know,
eight foot core,
whatever they say to tall women.
I don't know.
I don't remember.
It's been a long time since you've been in school.
A 100% of those people who said that to me 10 years ago are now pretty Chubby at
30.
While I look like the same slash better than I did at 20.
My boyfriend says I'm a 10 and he's a catcher and a half.
Uh,
I just looked up,
Gigi had his numbers,
five,
10 and a half tall,
130 pounds,
almost the exact same as this girls.
She should also look into squats,
leg lifts and protein.
Thanks to go fuck yourself.
So I think what she did was she embraced her body and made it the best she
could.
She could be.
I think that's all great advice.
Olive oil.
I hope you listening.
All right.
But,
uh,
only thing I would add to that,
just make sure you get a personal trainer,
get a nutritionist and all that stuff and they have the answers rather than
fucking looking at the dope next to you being like,
what,
what are those?
Okay.
Knows spray [inaudible] try.
I'll fucking,
I'll just,
I'll just do that.
Um,
okay.
Alexa at my hospital.
Oh Geez.
A dear bill.
I work in a medical center that is very up to date with technology in Beverly
Hills that I will not name my work involves me visiting patients at their
bedsides.
I walked into one of my patients from defined Alexa,
mounted on the wall with an example question typed up on a piece of paper.
Alexa,
call my nurse.
My reaction was,
she has a big fucking Emoji.
Looks like a smiley face.
Are you freaking out?
Is that a freaking out smiley face?
I Dunno.
And I asked the RN that's registered nurse.
Uh,
we have Alexa now.
As soon as I said Alexa,
it lit up with that creepy blue ring waiting for me to give it a command.
I have no idea why patients need that.
And then room because patients have remotes that call the nurse station.
Yeah.
Cause it's spine on you that also controls the TVS.
I mainly thought of you and chuckled,
love your work.
And I agree a lot with you lady m d c that this smart ladies go with old
freckles and you should go with those freckles.
A celebrity podcasts,
podcasts are this Tuesday in the voting booth.
Okay.
I say you vote for me.
Me,
me,
me.
Yeah,
yeah,
yes,
yes.
I saw the McRib advertise recently.
Must be voting season again.
Hilarious.
Um,
yeah,
that's all creepy.
You know,
flew in and out of Boston from Newark Airport and they had this magazine,
this is trivia to Burt Reynolds.
So it was like,
you know,
I,
it was great.
His movies,
his stunts,
the women he loved.
I was like,
oh,
I gotta read this fucking Burt Reynolds.
They're not going to make another guy like this.
Okay.
And,
um,
I go,
I pick up the magazine,
I'm looking around this,
nobody there.
So I walk over to the restaurant,
I go,
yeah,
where do I pay for this?
And The lady just goes,
oh,
at the self checkout right over there,
sweetheart.
And she points over to when it had to been 5 million fucking things.
So I just said,
oh,
okay.
It's right over there.
Okay,
well thank you sweetheart.
And I just walked over to the rack and I fucking put it back in.
I'm not doing it.
Okay.
Not fucking doing it.
That's another thing too.
I've fucking refuse to be my own cashier
drawn a line in the sand.
I will.
I will fucking eat a Goddamn thanksgiving meal before I go to the fucking
airport.
I'll bring my reader's digest.
I'm going to be that old guy.
I don't like new things.
Yeah.
And you know what?
No one's going to care,
Bill.
Nobody's going to care.
So just learn how to check yourself out in the mirror.
No silly at a store.
All right.
My wife cheated on me by downloading Tinder and sending nudes.
Hey,
Billy balls.
But listening to your podcast for a few years now and your advocacy,
this is somebody who never would have cheated in the past.
Yeah,
they just were around a computer too long.
I'm telling you,
it's like just having a heroin sitting on your table.
Eventually you're going to do some dumb anyways,
but,
but lets your podcast for a few years now and your advice always makes me laugh
and hard times.
Here's something that just happened to me this past week.
I was hoping you could help me out with,
I got married Memorial Day irony,
um,
of this year.
My wife has been acting really distanced lately and on Sunday I asked her if she
was seeing anyone.
She told me no,
I've known this girl for four years now and I knew she was lying.
Wow.
Do great instincts.
If you guys just got married in May,
this is five months later,
it's gone.
This has gotten this bad.
Okay.
When I asked to look at her phone,
she quickly deleted something and refuse to let me see your phone physically
attacking and scratching to keep me from seeing it.
She then admitted to downloading Tinder about two weeks ago and has been take
talking to a guy and send him some pictures,
claiming to never have met him.
Okay.
And I believe her.
I've been struggling these last few days with a lot of emotions.
It's only five months into the marriage.
Is it best to look at getting a divorce?
Okay.
It would take a lot of time to forget about what she did.
Especially since I will never really know what transpired.
Saw you and AC and loved it.
Thanks to go fuck yourself.
Yeah,
dude,
you're five months in.
Okay.
Well if you were like 10 years in,
you go going through a rocky period.
Okay.
I Dunno.
You gave a couple of kids.
It's something you work out maybe,
but
yeah.
This just seems like if this has happened in this early on,
I don't,
she wanted to marry.
That's what I would add or doesn't want to be married or I don't know what or
sabotage in the whole thing and at that point it's like,
well hey,
here's Kudos to you cause you did it.
Yeah,
I would get the fuck out of that.
Yeah.
I mean as a kid,
did you dream?
Does that,
was that your dream woman?
Five months in Senator [inaudible] fucking who Howard is some fun.
I don't think it is.
Um,
yeah,
I would,
I would get the fuck out of that.
You know,
not to mention she also like physically attach it to.
So I mean,
I dunno.
That's good.
There's a lot of that sounds like the beginning of one of those uh,
lady appear to be a happily married couples.
Occasionally he would showed up with odd scratches and bruises,
but he quickly explained it away saying he was working on his car.
Then one day he didn't show up for Thanksgiving.
His wife had recently been digging a well in the back yard.
All right.
Hate fat people.
Oh Jesus.
Dear Billy bitty balls.
Billy Betty balls.
Oh,
What's a matter?
Um,
I'm a 20 year old sophomore in college and I have a dilemma.
Like the subject says fat people really just disgusts me.
Oh,
the subject.
Kate flappy bar.
Uh,
there are too many examples to name,
but one that really gets me is this lady,
my math class who sits next to me and we'll ramp randomly start smacking her
lips and making this,
he spelled it m.
E.
H.
M ma'am.
Noise.
She's doing that and maybe she's thinking about food.
I don't know.
There was also this guy in my hall who shits literally three times a day.
Well,
he must be rapping his pizza and Kale or something because I see him go to Rome
with pounds of food at a time.
My dislike isn't anything malicious and I just can't help it.
But I just stuck between a rock and it's squishy place and surrounded on all
sides by the fatties.
I know this does not seem like a big,
that big of a deal,
but I have a bit of a temper and I'm afraid I'm going to say something to one of
the fatties and get title nine right out of my school.
Do you have any tips to become a bit more tolerant?
Uh,
love the podcast.
Congrats on your role in front runner.
You should grow that mustache and keep it and go fuck yourself.
Um,
I did grow that mustache.
I grew that mustache when I had a,
when I played the cop way back on Chappelle show.
Um,
let's see here.
Uh,
I would just make a joke out of it.
I,
well,
do you know the guy who was always disappeared?
Okay.
I would give him a sumo wrestler name.
Now you can't do that.
That's me.
I Dunno.
Yeah,
I know.
It's like a,
yeah,
you supposed to be tolerant,
but they just continue to eat and they make weird noises and they smell and you
supposed to just sit next to him and be like,
well I feel bad from,
they have a fucking problem.
Okay.
You know,
it's hard to feel bad for someone that you know is gluttonous I guess.
But that's just the way I'm wired.
Like a,
you know,
all of these fucking addicts and all these goddamn people.
Like I dunno,
once you live with the fucking attic,
you just,
uh,
yeah.
You just have,
you don't have a lot of patients from,
I don't really know what you're asking me,
so I understand what you're saying.
Um,
I would just find somebody else in shape and I would just together just make fun
of them without them being able to hear it.
And you know,
in most of the time they're chewing anyway,
so it drowns out there.
Hearing so I think you'll be all right.
I would just make jokes like that.
Other than that what he's supposed to do,
you know,
uh,
I dunno.
Sing songs when they go by.
Okay.
That'd be funny if he just snapped by Jesus Christ again.
How fat are you trying to fucking get?
You can't do any of that.
And the thing is is you're not really helping him.
Okay.
You shouldn't fat shame people,
but like,
it's also like,
you know what I mean?
Like,
you know,
there's a little bit of arsenic and an apple,
but it's still good for you.
Like it.
Yeah.
If you could have like the same level of arsenic that's in an apple,
if you could have that level of shame shaming and fat people,
I think it would help them out a little bit.
Why don't you tie one of them to your bumper and drag them to the gym?
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't have the answers here.
Um,
recipe from vegetable Lasagna.
Okay.
I have no fucking idea why I'm getting this.
Yeah.
Speaking of which,
um,
I have not been eating well.
I consider myself a fat fuck right now and I,
I fetch,
I'm,
I'm a self contained unit.
I will,
I will fat shame myself.
Um,
oh,
you guys can do it too.
You know,
I always enjoy that.
All right,
recipe for vegetables.
Anya.
Dear Bill,
I was recently listening to an old podcast.
Will you and Neil,
we're talking about a thanksgiving.
Oh God,
yes.
Well you made a shitty vegetarian lasagna with carrots in it.
It was horrible.
Oh my God.
One of the worst thanksgivings ever,
uh,
made me think of a great Broccoli lasagna recipe that my roommate and I would
cook.
Yeah.
And I would cook.
Uh,
he's half Italian from Sicily.
Well,
those guys don't consider themselves Italian.
They consider themselves Sicilian and the recipe is from his Italian
grandmothers.
See,
you know,
it's going to be some good shit.
Uh,
this isn't healthy at all.
It's rich and creamy and absolutely delicious as a Lasagna should be.
Also,
it's super easy.
I can't remember the exact measurements for each thing,
but we're going to try anyways.
Oh,
your protection.
The recipe while you gave me was the fucking ingredients.
What is this?
A cooking show,
700 grams of Broccoli,
Florence
flour,
butter and milk for the bechamel sauce.
Look up a basic lasagna recipe for Beck.
I'm B,
c h,
a m,
e l and amount of Lasagna sheets.
A few cloves of garlic,
chopped olive oil,
fresh Mozzarella Parmesan,
or a tablespoon of Pesto depending on how much back on mail you make.
Well,
let's see.
It's pretty simple.
Like all great Italian dishes.
Okay.
All right.
I'm not going to read all of this shit.
Cut Up the Broccoli.
All right.
I Dunno if somebody can figure that fucking shit out of it.
Uh,
anyways,
if I done an hour,
I think I have.
Um,
all right,
that's the podcast.
I don't know who's playing Monday night football tonight,
but I gotta do some spots tonight and tomorrow to make sure I'm ready for
Tuesday and into this weekend.
And,
um,
I'm actually going to do something that all old men like to do.
I'm going to take a fucking nap.
I can't wait.
And you guys,
you have no idea how difficult it is to be me.
You know,
dealing with Harding problems like cheerleading.
Should we let women cheerlead I love how their cheerleading five feet away from
guys who are literally doing irreparable brain damage to themselves,
most of whom you know,
when they get to a certain point,
either go crazy or killed themselves,
but,
but let's,
let's not focus on that.
Anyways,
that's the podcast.
Everybody,
I'll check in on you on Thursday and uh,
I dunno what I guess now I'm down to watch and uh,
going to start watching the Celtics and the Bruins.
Now when I get fucking home to my,
my,
uh,
what is center ice package and one of the,
they call the basketball one,
the NBA hardcourt package.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
His package to a,
is that micro aggressive?
My uh,
Santa Rice Vagina?
Is that what you supposed to say?
I have no idea.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves please.
Everybody.
Just,
just for me and my celebrity podcasting ego.
Could you kiss,
get out there and vote cause tomorrow is really,
really important.
All right,
go fuck yourselves.
We'll talk to you Thursday.